مرحبا بكم في هذه النافذه الانسانيه
الخاصه بتداعيات حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه
على مختلف الصع سينضم الينا من عمان سليم
عويس المتحدث الاقليمي باسم اليونيسيف و
سنسلط الضوء على واقع القطاع التربوي في
قطاع غزه في اليوم العالمي للتعليم وبعد
مرور 110 ايام على الحرب نشير في البدايه
الى ما اعلنته وزاره الصحه في غزه بان عدد
الشهداء ارتفع الى
25700 شهيد منذ السابع من اكتوبر الماضي و
الى
6374 مصابا منذ بدايه العدوان واشارت
الوزاره الى ان
70% من ضحايا الحرب الاسرائيليه هم من
النساء والاطفال كما قال المكتب الاعلامي
الحكومي ان هناك 7000 مفقود تحت الانقاض
او مصيرهم مجهول وبلغه الارقام نستعرض معا
ماساه القطاع التربوي في قطاع غزه حرمان
اكثر من
625000 طالب من التعليم منذ بدايه الحرب
وحرمان
2 ال معلم من مهنه التدريس منذ بدء
الاعمال العدائيه خمسه و
7% من المباني المدرسيه في قطاع غزه
متضرره بالاضافه الى تعرض مؤسسات التعليم
العالي ايضا لاضرار واستهداف 300 ال
تلميذ في مدارس الاونروا حرموا من التعليم
بعد اعلان الاونروا اغلاق جميع مدارسها في
قطاع غزه نعود الى ضيفنا من عمان سليم
عويس المتحدث الاقليمي باسم اليونيسيف سيد
سليم مرحبا بك معنا اذا استهداف متعمد
ومحدد حسب مراكز المراقبه التي تراقب ما
يجري في القطاع التعليمي خاصه كيف تصنف
لنا حجم الاضرار من حيث الكوادر التعليميه
من حيث الطلاب ومن حيث
المباني نعم يعني كما تفضلت للاسف حجم
الدمار للقطاع التعليمي كبير جدا ح نتحدث
كما كما اسلفت حضرتك اكثر من 625 ال طالب
الان خارج المدرسه كل اطفال غزه الان منذ
10 ايام تقريبا لا يطلقون التعليم الذي
يستحقونه نحن اليوم يعني في في اليوم
العالمي للتعليم ونحن ننادي بحق الاطفال
جميعهم في التعليم الان الاطفال في قطاع
غزه لا يحصلون على اي تعليم وحتى محاولات
ال على الارض غير ناجعه لانه لا مكان امن
الان لتقديم اي نوع من التعليم نحن نتكلم
ايضا عن تفضلت بان 75% من المدارس هي اما
متضرره او مدمره ولكن الرقم المهول الاكثر
ان 90% من المدارس الان هي بين مدمره
متضرره او تستخدم ك كمون هذا هذا يعكس
واقع الحال في قطاع غزه طبعا هذا واقع
الواقع الانساني ولكن ايضا تداعياته على
الواقع التعليمي وعلى مستقبل الاطفال نحن
الان لا نخاطر فقط بعشرات
الالاف من الاطفال اي يعني تقريبا مليون
ف1
اي طفل
نخاطر بحياتهم ولكن نخاطر ايضا بمستقبل
اولئك من ينجون من من الموت ا سيد سليم
يعني في اليوم العالمي للتعليم ما الذي
بوسع المنظمات الامميه المعنيه
باهميه هذا القطاع من اجل النشء القادم في
المستقبل ما الذي بامكانها ان تفعله مع
هذا الكم الهائل من الاحتياجات وهذا الكم
الهائل من الفقدان ل الكوادر التعليميه
وللطلاب وايضا
للمباني نعم للاسف على ارض الواقع لا يمكن
لنا بتقديم الخدمات التعليميه او المساعده
في التعليم حتى يتوقف العنف لانه الان
فعلا كما كما قلت لك قبل قليل كل محاولات
لانشاء ولو مكان امن للاطفال ليلعبوا فيه
او ليعودوا الى نوع من الطبيعي في حياتهم
وهذا هذا ما هو يعني جزء
من الهدف من وراء المدارس المدارس ليست
فقط للتعليم ولكن ايضا هناك نوع
من الاتصال النفسي والعاطفي بالمدرسه نوع
من الامان داخل المدرسه للاسف حتى هذا غير
غير متاح الان لاطفال غزه ما نستطيع فعله
وما ما نفعله على مدار الساعه ونحاول فعله
هو كاي منظمه انسانيه هوق تقديم محاوله
تقديم المساعدات ان كان وهذا ما كنا نحاول
فعله تقديم جزء من ال الخدمات ما يسمى
بالخدمات الترفيهيه ولكن هي اكثر منها
ترفيهيه هي الخدمات التي فعلا تغير تركيز
الاطفال من واقع الحرب الى القليل من
اللعب القليل من من الطبيعيه كما كما
اسلفت وقد قدمت لعشرات الاف من من الطلاب
في قطاع
زه بما في ذلك اولئك من يعانون من او
يعني ذوي اعاقه ولكن كل ما يجري على الارض
بدون وقف فوري لاطلاق
النار لن يكون سوى ضماده فعلا يعني قصيره
المدى للاسف هذا هو الواقع نحاول بكل
جهدنا في منظمه اليونيسيف هل يجري التقييم
عمليه تقييم حجم الاضرار بالتالي من اجل
يعني وضع الخطط في المستقبل
ل ترميم هذه الاضرار التي
حصلت بالطبع هذا هذا جزء كبير وهذا ما
نحاول فعله مره اخرى بالرغم من صعوبه
الواقع على الارض وصعوبه حركه طواقمنا على
الارض
يعني وهذا ما يعني قلناه في العديد من
المناسبات قطاع غزه ليس هناك مكان امن في
قطاع غزه لا للاطفال لا للمدنيين ولا
لعمال الاغاثه او الموظفين ان كانوا اممين
او غيرهم للاسف هذا هو الواقع الان ولكن
هذا عملنا لذلك يعني هذه الارقام التي
ذكرتيه 75% من المدارس او 90% من المدارس
التي تستخدم كمون او متضرره كل هذا جزء من
التقييم وهذا سيبنى عليه ليتم تقييم اكثر
لاعداد الخطط ولكن مره اخرى من المبكر جدا
ان نتكلم باي خطط ان لم يكن هناك
يعني الامل بان تتوقف تتوقف هذه الحرب وان
يكون هناك وقف اطلاق نار لذلك الدعوه
الاساسيه لوقف اطلاق النار الدعوه
الاساسيه للس سماح بدخول المساعدات بشكل
اكبر وجزء من المساعدات هو المساعدات
الدعم النفسي الذي يحتاجه
الاطفال الجزء التعليمي وما الى ذلك كل
هذا مهم جدا لضمان ان الاطفال عندما
يخرجون من هذه الازمه يكون لديهم القدره
لمواصله تعليمهم ول يعني مواصله حياتهم
للاسف الان المخاطره هي ان تنتهي هذه
الحرب ولكن العديد من العائلات لن تستطيع
من مغادره المدارس التي تاوي فيها بسبب
دمار بيوتهم وهذا يعني جانب مهم جدا وجزء
من المخاوف لدينا شكرا جزيلا لك من عمان
سليم عويس المتحدث الاقليمي باسم
اليونيسيف
ختام هذه النافذه الانسانيه عوده الى
الزملاء في غرفه الاخبار لمتابعه بقيه
التغطيه